bonjour à tous j'espère que vous
m'aimiez
ont naturellement pour vous remercier
d'être là d'habitude de notre réunion de
rentrée nos journées de rentrée nous
avait lieu dit elle assez souvent le
temps était aussi beau qu'il est
aujourd'hui dans les pyrénées mais cette
année évidemment ça n'était pas possible
pour toutes les raisons que nous savons
et sur lesquels nous allons réfléchir
parce qu'ils sont plus calmes
donc il ce qu'ils expriment et j'ai un
mot particulier naturellement pour
michel barnier qui avait qui nous lie ne
traîne longue complicité
je suis entendu naturellement tous nous
avons conscience qu'il a entre les mains
un enjeu absolument crucial non pas
seulement pour nom royaume uni par les
liens entre et l'union européenne mais
un enjeu crucial pour la nature de
l'union européenne si l'union européenne
accepte et de laisser se créer une sorte
de singapour à ces guerres qui serait
une plate forme pour que le commerce
l'emportent sur d'autres considérations
et qu'on rejette donc on a 1000 dézempte
les normes toutes les préoccupations que
nous voulons prendre tout le soutien que
ma portée adp pratiques en matière j
coûts en matière de santé ou en matière
de protection sociale des travailleurs
qu'ils soient les nôtres alors ça veut
dire que nous devons être extrêmement
rigoureux dans la manière dont nous
allons avoir noué des relations avec ce
nouveau pays pierre qui est le royaume
uni et puis je vous remercie et
jean-noël barrot d'abord de son
expression de son travail
et vous me permettez de dire qu'au
travers de lui je souhaite remercier
toutes les équipes qui d'un autre
mouvement extrêmement réduite
comment la litté comme je tiens à le
souligner chaque fois que nécessaire ces
équipes qui qui qui nous permettent non
seulement d'avoir une vie de deux partis
politiques très nourris mais aussi
d'innover ce que nous avons fait là
cette innovation avec cité démocrate ces
journées où les débats les rondes les
liens l'expérience dentaire des membres
du gouvernement que je salue jacqueline
gourault chez nos jeunes nathalie tous
et tous ces débats ont pu avoir lieu de
la manière la plus efficace possible
étant donné la défilé temps de préparer
avec un clin d'oeil est instruite à un
militant dans notre parc depuis très
louable donc qu'on réfléchisse à une
organisation une fédération internet
ce militant bien qu'ils soient président
du parti un parfois du mal à se faire
entendre sur ce sujet comme ça fait à
peu près dix ans que et encore je suis
probablement notre test que j'essaie de
convaincre les responsables autour de
moi de faire ça alors je peux rappeler
que je suis persuadé qu'il y a dans
cette organisation nouvelle quelque
chose de très précieux à construire
naturellement je veux vous dire que au
moment de ces journées je pense beaucoup
et vous aussi
donc je sais qu'elle est ré engagé en
dépit de de l'épreuve de santé très
lourde qu'elle traverse qu'elle est très
engagée qu'elle décroche son téléphone
pour appeler les uns et les autres et
les rappeler à ce devoir de de
créativité d'indépendance est le nôtre
c'est une c'est une personnalité très
respectée les politiques françaises et
ans comme tout le monde le sait on a eu
très peur mais j'ai espoir que
aujourd'hui elle réussit ça a sûrement
les passages si difficile qu'elle
traverse et je ne voulais pas de queue
on est donc il ya un message direct
qu'elle m'a donné qu'elle m'a demandé de
vous transmettre
merci à stan guérini de de son message
de sa présence
et puis merci aussi de sa simplicité et
de son amitié de son authenticité
c'est un jeune responsables politiques
comme jean noël barrot les comme ça
allait c'est un jeune responsable
politique mais il a je crois de de la
profondeur et de l'enracinement je suis
contente de pouvoir
le salut est devant vous on est dans une
situation singulière parce que
d'habitude quand il y à une alliance de
partis politiques ce sont des courants
doctrinaux ou idéologiques différents
ici ça n'est pas le cas nous avons nous
notre propre histoire notre propre si
vous être propre
et ex personne ouvertement l'inversé
beaucoup de rage on a on a rencontré
beaucoup de grain et beaucoup de
tempêtes
ça a forgé entre nous une solidarité
très importante et vous savez bien à
quel point cette solidarité avec avec
marc avec patrick avec jacqueline avec
marielle est forte et vivante est en
marche c'est un mouvement différent ce
moment qui s'est constituée au moment de
la présidentielle
autour du président de la république et
donc ça me fait une identité différente
pas antagonistes c'est au fond le tout
est prêt tout est disposée pour qu'il y
ait la meilleure entente possible entre
nous et c'est cette entente que nous
voulons faire vivre et puis je salue le
premier ministre
je ne sais pas si nous écoute mais tout
à l'heure nous l'entendons et je savais
le poids de ministres parce que il est
une voire pardon de dire sa nouvelle
pour beaucoup de français dans la
politique nationale qu'il a beaucoup
d'atouts dans son jeu et dans un jeu qui
est très difficile il a beaucoup
d'atouts parce qu'il a une expérience de
l'aide parce que il a occupé beaucoup de
fonctions de responsabilité de terrain
parce qu'élu local
parce qu'ils les pyrénéens c'est à dire
qu'il dans sa manière d'être et de faire
une identité qui est identité pour moi
très précieuse je pense que la france a
beaucoup trop souffert d'uniformité et
qu'elle en souffre encore je reviendrai
peut-être dans une minute et donc jeudi
le premier ministre belge et son
expérience et sa détermination
voilà le des remerciements que je
voulais exprimer
je le ferai à la fin les équipes
techniques qui nous ont permis cette
nouvelle nous vivons qui sera dans les
livres d'histoire ce monde et pis démis
inattendue je ne dis pas imprévisible
parce que je pense qu'elle était
prévisible ou qu'en tout cas on pouvait
prendre des précautions nécessaires pour
avoir les réflexes les bons réflexes et
les bons équipements au moment où
seraient ce des mécènes et me elle
change tout elle songe tout on le voit
bien d'autres manières de militer d'être
ensemble
elle change tout dans la vie quotidienne
nous sommes pour la première fois de
notre vie tous dans une société où
l'ennui en brasse où l'on de soustara
on ne voyait plus guère la crise des
transports aériens des compagnies et
même des constructeurs aéronautiques est
une crise évidemment extrêmement le
monde et qui changent notre manière
d'être et notre vie ça va changer un sur
le commerce international va nous faire
une science de 1 très grand nombre de
difficultés et de manque que nous avons
découvert avec 7 avec cette crise
[Musique]
cette crise elle nous impose
de réfléchir à notre vie démocratique
d'une manière différente
nous savons bien tout ce qu' il n'y a
pas que l'économie qui soit tant qu'il
n'y a pas que la vie sociale qui soit en
crise il y à aussi fière de débattre de
lycées précision et cette manière là
elle doit en particulier nous obliger à
sortir de la dictature de l'urgence des
réseaux sociaux qui sont perpétuelles
explosion ébullition tsunami holy
tsunami ne dure pas longtemps
mais n'importe quel événement
microscopique donne lieu à une explosion
un panache de fumée comme si c'était
l'éruption du vésuve et donc il faut
qu'on apprenne à vivre avec ça faut
qu'on apprenne à vivre avec eux et
chaîne de télévision 10 nuls 24 il faut
qu'on apprenne à vivre avec eux les
mouvements de l'opinion et il faut qu'on
apprenne à vivre à comptes publics a
voulu faire confiance à tout responsable
réintroduisant
le temps long la venus d'horizons les
mouvements qu'on ne voit pas toujours
mais dans notre vie dépend les très
grands mouvements de la planète et de
l'univers
les sujets qui vont commander notre
futur y compris notre futur lointain des
ré introduire dans le débat et dans la
décision quotidien c'est ce qu'on
appelle le plan c'est choisir des
horizons à mais un chemin évidemment
c'est d'abord la responsabilité du
président de la république et c'est
pourquoi notre soutien au président de
la république est un soutien actif au
présent et amicale parce que je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait un président qui dans
les années récentes et connu des crises
aussi multiple est aussi dangereuse que
celle que d'un kenna d'emmanuel
d'affaires est cependant dans ce
quinquennat là il est à responsabilité
et il est selon pleinement à la hauteur
de cette fonction
et ça mérite évidemment du soutien donc
au tour du président de la république un
ré habitants de lointains temps la
réussite croirait tout droit et je vais
reprendre celle que le président de la
république
à fixer à la mission que j'ai accepté on
a une série de questions qui tournent
autour du grand sujet qui se regroupent
autour du grand sujet de l'indépendance
ça ne sert à rien de faire de la
politique ça ne sert à rien d'avoir des
débats d'organiser des parties est
d'avoir un parlement et un gouvernement
style
nous ne somme être de protestants or il
se trouve
comme beaucoup d'entre nous ne savent
que sur bien des sujets la maîtrise de
notre destin nous a alors l'épidémie
nous a permis de découvrir que nous
n'étions plus capables d'obtenir les
médicaments qui sont indispensables à
notre système de santé
nous avons manqué dans cette épidémie
être je n'insiste pas nous manque encore
des équipes des médicaments du monde
essentiels que sont les médicaments
contre le cancer que son compte était
pendant l'épidémie est médicalement pour
qu'ils permettent de faire est de
sécuriser les médis
antibiotiques aux portes mêmes à des
molécules aussi élémentaires que ce
qu'on appelle doliprane en général c'est
à dire le paracétamol et donc et cela
parce condamne à la délocaliser la
production
parce que la plupart de ces molécules
coûte évidemment ne rapporter plus assez
dans leur fabrication
on préférait se tourner vers des
molécules absolument nouvelle et qui
rapportent beaucoup plus et donc cette
cette question de l'indépendance de des
productions mais elle ne faut pas aller
très loin dans l'électronique
évidemment ce tome 2 et puis et c'est
pour moi que physiquement insupportable
nous sommes dépendants des décisions
d'autres puissances sur la planète sur
notre propre souveraineté
j'ai cité souvent mais je veux leur
faire devant vous lorsque les états unis
ont décidé de sanctions contre l'iran
il a fallu que les entreprises
françaises et européennes qui était
installée en iran qui ne dépendait pas
des états unis qui n'était pas à
capitaux américains
il a fallu que ces entreprises quitte
cependant le sol iranien dans les 15
jours parce qu'il ya des dispositions
internationales que les états unis en te
impose et qui font que nous n'avons plus
une preuve d indépendance ses passes
évidemment seulement l'indépendance
française
il s'agit tout autant d'indépendance
européenne
je n'aurais eu aucune crainte sur notre
système de santé si des médicaments
les médicaments dont j'ai parlé avait
été produit en allemagne les oreilles
on les aurait obtenu sans aucune
difficulté probable si problème madame
industrie donc je fais pour moi j'ai un
seul je fais un seul instant pl un seul
bloc 2 l'indépendance de la france et de
l'est et de l'indépendance de l'europe
qui comme nous l'avons répété tout au
long de cette matinée sont un seul et
même problème et puis y'a il ya une
deuxième grande question qui est
vitalité de notre société qui est à
citer d'autres pays a fait renaître des
entreprises à produire de la recherche a
innové en matière scientifique et
technique à protéger nos inventions à à
avoir au fond la une une vie local
national régional qui n'a plus ce point
de vue la beauté qui tiennent souvent à
la manière dont est organisé et on peut
libérer cette vitalité en tout cas c'est
le deuxième sujet qu'il faut traiter un
troisième sujet qui est le plus
important de tous souhaitent être mieux
commencer par l'appareil n'aurait pas
été logique du point de vue cours c'est
le sujet de justice car nous portons un
modèle et une rester vis-à-vis de nos
enfants et vis-à-vis du monde dans ce
grand sujet de justice il ya évidemment
au premier degré la question de du
climat de la planète de l'environnement
de la biodiversité la responsabilité qui
est la nôtre
pas seulement en tant que citoyen
français d'européens père de famille de
notre continent ou régions du monde mais
en tant que ça du monde et citoyens de
la planète
et cette raison ce sujet de justice
naturellement il faut qu'on le il faut
qu'on le traite puis la justice s'est
dit des choses que le chant du doigt je
vais je vais essayer d'en dire trois
lumières ce sont les pâtures
territoriale suit à l'âme jeu je pense à
jacqueline en visant s'impose qu'elle a
la responsabilité ministérielle mais je
compte beaucoup traiter ces questions
avec la responsabilité et du plan il ya
ce petit bilan ont tant qu'on ne s'est
pas occupé d'aménagement et je jetterai
souvent discuté de ça embellit le
président de la république parce que
comme vous savez c'est un provincial
d'enracinement et les pyrénées en
particulier pas seulement mais mes euros
de france aussi sont pour lui une terre
d'attachement mais il ya si longtemps
qu'on s'est pas occupé de ça il ya si
longtemps qu'on croit que tout se joue à
paris et quand on dit à paris
sajid naturellement pas de tous les
quartiers de paris il s'agit de du tout
petits de la toute petite surface rive
gauche rive droite sur laquelle se
nouent et se dénouent les débats
médiatiques et politiques
eh bien il est d'irriguer à nouveau la
france de responsabilités et je dis que
le boulet loeffler pour la
responsabilité eux qui est la mienne
michel manière à créer une exemplarité
les régions les villes et pas seulement
les métropoles de province les régions
les villes et bourgs ont besoin de
retrouver de la seigne est de montrer
que deux chez eux de leurs terres de
leurs terrains la remontée jusqu'au 6
et c'est pour ça que j'étais si content
que ce soit un élu local de notre co
province lointaine pyrénéenne que qui se
voit confier la responsabilité d'être
chef du gouvernement il ya une deuxième
fracture à laquelle je compte qu'on
s'attaque c'est les fractures de destin
il ya eu tout un temps où l'on savait
quand on était ouvrier paysan hinault
garde barrière est dans une bulle très
mais ce qu'il fait les enfants
réussissent et les seulement qu'il
travaille bien à l'école et c'est
pourquoi les instituteurs les
professeurs étaient à ce point valoriser
dans la société française ça n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui et on ne connaît plus
le chemin ou plus exactement ne
connaissent le chemin que les familles
favorisées par le destin qui ont de
bonnes questions et une bonne
connaissance des regards des ne serait
ce que pour trouver un stage quand on
est en troisième par exemple ou quand on
fait une formation par alternance
les fractures de destins sont tous
capables de l'art et les réponses à
apporter au fond tout ça se résume en
une question extrêmement graves et
douloureuses qui est la question de
culture dans la société française entre
la base la plus large les citoyens
quelle que soit la situation économique
dans laquelle ils sont et puis depuis le
prétendu sommet de la société les
prétendues élites et je mets tous les
guillemets et toutes les italiques que
vous imaginez devant devant cette
expression il ya très longtemps que la
base ne se reconnaît plus dans son
sommeil et même quand le sommet et deux
valeurs le seul fait qu'ils soient
situés en situation de responsabilité
entraîne le sur les privilèges sur
l'argent les les bénéfices supposés des
fonctions même si ça n'est pas
vérifiable ou vrai c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'ai voulu exercer la fonction
que le président de la république et le
conseil des ministres m'ont confié de
manière bénévole pour que cette question
totalement écartée qu'on comprenne qu'on
peut avoir uniquement comme
préoccupations d'intérêt général voilà
des sujets qui sont devant nous qu'on va
devoir affronter différemment avec les
yeux ouverts et j'espère la
considération que il existe un chemin
pour l'avenir et tout ça tout cela nous
aurons nous allons le faire ensemble
dans le faire en sorte de nous sommes un
courant politique une formation
politique
une deux sessions autour desquels s'est
construite en lice
nous avons cette chance cette
responsabilité d'incarner un grand
courant certains diront réformiste moi
j'ai j'ai toujours privilégié le mot de
démocratie démocrates et démocrates
d'inspiration des démocrates avaient une
idée à bhl les démocrates qui que c'est
pas seulement de répétition qu'il s'agit
s'agit de résoudre le responsable
politique que soit son grade par l'idée
que ce qu'il tient entre les mains de
plus précieux de vivre des gens dont ils
convinrent il pense
d'une certaine manière qu'au fond ça
n'est pas pour rien qu'il travaille ça
n'est pas pour rien qu'ils élèvent des
enfants pas pour rien qu'ils affrontent
les difficultés des temps et ma rage et
c'est parce que on construit quelque
chose et on construit quelque chose dont
on pense qu'il doit être meilleur pour
l'avenir
voilà là la responsabilité que nous
vivons précisément dans ce courant
politique si dans le mouvement démocrate
qui aujourd'hui et je crois qu'on peut
le dire de mieux en mieux reconnue et
estimée dans la vie politique française
alors je vous remercie d'avoir organisé
cette rencontre je dis merci aux équipes
techniques qui l'ont fait ni pied et jeu
et je remercie tous ceux qui participent
les intervenants doit simplement
connecté avec la réflexion que nous
menons
je suis très heureux de passer la parole
au premier ministre jean k
remercie présence et de sa participation